.
IT'S WEDNESDAY NIGHT IN
NASHVILLE.
ORISKANY LIKES TO CALL IT KNOW,
OFFICER, THOSE ARE NOT MY DRUGS
DAY.
SHE IS JUST HOLDING THEM FOR A
FRIEND.
A FRIEND NAMED KEITH RICHARDS.
WHAT A GREAT SHOW, JOINING US,
CANDACE OWENS.
CANDACE HAS MORE HATERS ON THE
LEFT THAN PERSONAL HYGIENE.
THAT SAYS SOMETHING.
IF SHE WERE ANY SMARTER AND
BEAUTIFUL, SHE WOULD BE ME.
OH, LOOK WHO HAS JOINED US, THE
CHARMING PETE HEGSETH.
YOU NO, HE SMILES AND NOW THE
WHOLE FRONT ROW IS PREGNANT.
THIS GUY HAS MORE THAN THE CARDS
FOR KIDS COMMERCIAL.
GIVES THE LADIES MORE HOT
FLASHES AND MENOPAUSE.
LIKE A HERSHEY BAR LEFT IN THE
HOT CAR, WHEN PETE IS ON TV, THE
WOMEN JUST UP THERE AND MELT.
NOT JUST THE WOMEN.
OF COURSE WE HAVE KAT.
THERE SHE IS.
SINCE SHE HAS BEEN IN NASHVILLE,
SHE HAS REALLY EMBRACED THE
COWBOY LIFESTYLE.
I GIVE HER POINTS FOR TRYING.
WE HAD TO PUT DOWN THE HORSE."
THIS TIRES.
AND OF COURSE THERE IS TYRUS.
I'LL JUST MOVE ON.
WE'VE GOT TO THANK THE AMAZING
AUDIENCE HERE TONIGHT.
WE LOVE YOU BECAUSE YOU CHOSE US
OVER ALL THE OTHER STUFF, LIKE
THE CRAP CURRENTLY ON LATE-NIGHT
TV AND I CAN'T SAY I BLAME YOU.
HAVE YOU SEEN WHAT IS ON
COLBERT?
♪ ♪
IT'S A BUNCH OF NEEDLES AND ONE
ANNOYING PRICK.
TOO EASY.
THAT'S TOO EASY.
ALL RIGHT.
THAT CLIP WAS FROM JUNE BUT IT'S
LIKE FINDING 20 BOOKS UNDER SEAT
CUSHION.
IT MAY BE OLD BUT IT'S NEW TO
US.
WHO KNEW ONE OF THE SIDE EFFECTS
OF THE JAB WAS IMMEDIATE CANCER
OF THE FUNNY BONE?
THAT WAS SO BAD IT GAVE
COURTNEY LOVE A FEAR OF NEEDLES.
THE AUDIENCE PROBABLY WISHED
THOSE NEEDLES WERE FILLED WITH
CYANIDE.
IT'S NOT AN ARGUMENT AGAINST
VACCINE.
IT'S AN ARGUMENT FOR LETHAL
INJECTION.
I FEAR YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
DRINK A WHOLE BOTTLE OF TEQUILA
TO RECOVER FROM THIS.
OR AS KAT CALLS IT, A JUICE
CLEANSE.
>> Kat: I'M A NICE PERSON.
>> Greg: YOU ARE.
SPEAKING OF VOMITING, THAT'S NOT
THE ONLY THING MAKING US SICK.
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" PUBLISHED A
REDESIGN OF THE AMERICAN FLAG
BECAUSE YOU KNOW THE CURRENT ONE
REEKS OF WHITE PRIVILEGE.
LOOK AT THIS ONE.
WHAT THE HELL IS THIS?
I DON'T KNOW WHETHER TO SALUTE
IT OR CALIBRATE THE COLOR OF MY
NEW FLAT SCREEN.
IF YOUR CHILD SHOWED YOU THAT,
YOU KICK THE BRAT OUT OF ARTS
AND CRAFTS.
IF IT REPEATS KID HE WOULD LEAD
BY THE ROADSIDE ON FAMILY
VACATION.
HE'S GOT PLENTY OF SPARES.
WHAT IS HE CARED.
LOOK AT THIS ONE.
IT IS CALLED LIFT EVERY VOICE
AND SING.
I CALL IT OPEN EVERY MOUTH AND
PUKE.
DO THESE PEOPLE UNDERSTAND WHAT
A FLAG IS QUESTION MARKET IS
SUPPOSED TO INSPIRE PATRIOTISM,
NOT AN ANEURYSM.
THEN THERE IS THIS ONE.
THIS ONE IS GIVING ME A MIGRAINE
JUST LOOKING AT IT.
MY EYES KNOW HOW MY EARS FEEL
WHEN AOC SPEAKS.
IF YOU'RE GOING TO GIVE ME A
HANGOVER, AT LEAST LET ME EARN
IT BY DRINKING.
THAT'S NOT A FLAG.
IT'S THE WALLPAPER IN A $5 A
NIGHT MOTEL IN NEW JERSEY.
NOT THAT I WOULD KNOW.
THAT WAS QUITE A WEEKEND, PETE.
THE PATTERN FOR A CLOWN'S
PAJAMAS.
SPEAKING OF CLOUDS AND PAJAMAS,
HOW IS JOE DOING?
ACCORDING TO AN "ABC NEWS" POLL,
PUBLIC APPROVAL OF HOW HE'S
HANDLING KEY ISSUES IS ERODING
FASTER THAN HUNTER'S SEPTUM.
I CARE ABOUT HIS HEALTH.
BY THE WAY, WHEN THIS POLL SAYS
KEY ISSUES, THEY ARE TALKING
ABOUT HOW LONG IT TAKES JOE TO
FIND HIS KEYS EVERY MORNING.
BUT WHEN IT COMES TO POLLING, HE
IS MORE UNDERWATER THAN A TED
KENNEDY DATE.
OH, YOU FEEL BAD ABOUT THAT?
DON'T KILL ANYBODY THEN.
OH, WE'LL FIND IT SOMEONE WHO
LEFT OH GIRL DIED.
MY APOLOGIES.
WE OFFENDED SOMEONE WHO LET A
GIRL DIE.
THE NUMBERS ARE LIKE JOE'S TEETH
IN A GLASS NEXT TO HIS BED,
FLOATING AT THE BOTTOM AND HE
MAKES IT WORSE BY MAKING CRAP UP
THAT'S HYSTERICAL.
COLBERT SHOULD HIRE HIM AS A
WRITER.
THE $3.5 TRILLION SPENDING BILL
ACTUALLY COST US NOTHING.
YEAH, TELL US, JOE.
>> EVERY TIME I HEAR, THIS IS
GOING TO COST ABC OR DO YOU, THE
TRUTH IS, BASED ON THE
COMMITMENT I MADE, IT'S GOING TO
COST NOTHING BECAUSE WE ARE
GOING TO RAISE THE REVENUE.
>> Greg: SURE YOU ARE, GRAMPS,
AND I'M GOING TO START FOR THE
CELTICS NEXT YEAR.
NOT THIS YEAR.
>> SOME HAVE EXPRESSED PUBLICLY
THAT THEY'RE NOT COMFORTABLE
WITH 3.5, EVEN THOUGH ZERO COSTS
$0.
>> Greg: SOME HAVE DISAGREED
PUBLICLY WITH YOU AND WHY?
BECAUSE WE AREN'T STUPID AND WE
AREN'T SUCKERS.
WHAT TOTAL STREET: THIS IS.
IT'S TOTALLY FREE BECAUSE WE'RE
GOING TO MAKE THE MONEY
AFTERWARDS BY TAXING THE HELL
OUT OF YOU BUT BY THE TIME WE
STEAL THAT MONEY WILL HAVE
ANOTHER TRILLION DOLLAR BILL
WHICH AGAIN WILL PAY FOR LATER
BY TAXING THE HELL OUT OF YOU.
IT NEVER ENDS.
LATHER, RINSE, REPEAT.
IN JOE'S CASE, LATHER, RINSE,
FALL BETWEEN THE SINK AND
TOILET.
IT'S NOT A BUDGET.
IT'S A PYRAMID SCHEME.
ONE STEP FROM SELLING HOUSEHOLD
CLEANING SUPPLIES FROM YOUR
TRUNK.
SO WE ELECTED BIDEN AND INSTEAD
WE GOT BERNIE MADE OFF AND
APPARENTLY THE SPENDING BILL
INCLUDES FREE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
FOR ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
WHICH GIVEN THE STATE OF OUR
EDUCATION SYSTEM SHOULD BE
CONSIDERED CRUEL AND INHUMAN
PUNISHMENT.
BY THE TIME THEY GRADUATE THEY
WON'T BE QUALIFIED FOR ANYTHING
THAT THEY WILL HAVE LEARNED 15
NEW PRONOUNS FOR A BEARDED LADY.
WHAT DOES JOE HAVE TO SAY FOR
HIMSELF?
>> EVERYBODY'S ASKING ME, JOE,
WHAT IS THIS GOING TO COST ME?
WHAT AM I GOING TO OH?
STAYED WITH UNCLE JOE AND YOU
WILL OWE NOTHING.
>> Greg: DID HE SAY WHAT I
THINK HE SAID?
>> STICK WITH UNCLE JOE AND YOU
WILL OWN NOTHING.
>> YOU WILL OWE NOTHING.
>> Greg: THAT'S WHAT I THOUGHT
HE SAID.
LUCKILY FOR THIS WHITE HOUSE,
THEY CAN TRUST THE MEDIA TO BACK
UP THE B.S.
THIS IS AN ACTUAL HEADLINE FROM
"THE WASHINGTON POST."
STOP FOCUSING ON THE NEGATIVE.
BIDEN AND HARRIS HAVE GOTTEN
THINGS DONE.
YEAH, YEAH, STOP FOCUSING ON THE
BAD STUFF.
THAT'S LIKE TELLING A DEATH ROW
INMATE THAT HIS LAST MEAL IS
GLUTEN-FREE.
BUT HEY, MAYBE WE SHOULD
CONSIDER ALL THE GOOD THINGS THE
WHITE HOUSE HAS DONE.
LET'S GO THROUGH THE LIST.
♪ ♪
[LAUGHTER]
>> Greg: IT'S SO JUVENILE.
BY THE WAY, DOING NOTHING ISN'T
A BAD THING.
LOOK HOW FAR IT HAS GOTTEN KAT.
THE THING IS, WE ARE IN A
DESTRUCTION LOOP.
GOVERNMENT CREATES A PROBLEM AND
THEN DEMANDS MONEY TO PAY FOR
IT.
IT'S LIKE THE GUY THAT BREAKS 50
STOREFRONT WINDOWS AND THEN
OPENS A GLASS COMPANY THE NEXT
DAY.
THAT'S OUR GOVERNMENT WHICH IS
WHY I PREFER A GOVERNMENT THAT
SITS ON ITS HANDS BECAUSE THEN
IT'S HANDS AREN'T GOING THROUGH
YOUR WALLET OR GRABBING YOUR
ASS.
LET'S WELCOME TONIGHT'S GUESTS.
LIKE SLEEPING ON A WATER BED,
SHE'S ALWAYS MAKING WAVES.
CONSERVATIVE COMMENTATOR AND
HOST OF "CANDACE" ON THE DAILY
WIRE, CANDACE OWENS.
BACK HOME IN MINNESOTA,
THEY CALL HIM THE ORIGINAL
"HOT DISH."
AND HE'S TWO KIDS AWAY FROM
A STARTING A LINE-UP.
"FOX AND FRIENDS WEEKEND"
CO-HOST PETE HEGSETH.
THE ONLY THING NEAT ABOUT HER
IS HOW SHE DRINKS HER WHISKEY.
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR KAT TIMPF.
AND WHEN HE RIDES THE MECHANICAL
BULL, THE BULL HAS TO SIGN
A WAIVER.
MY MASSIVE SIDEKICK AND THE
NWA'S WORLD TELEVISION CHAMPION,
TYRUS.
LET'S GET TO THE SHOW.
PETE, HERO TO HERO.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE.
>> THANK YOU FOR YOURS.
>> Greg: YOU HAVE A LOT OF
AMERICAN FLAG TATTOOS.
ARE YOU GOING TO HAVE TO
REDESIGN YOUR TATTOOS IF THEY
CHANGE THE FLAG?
>> IT'S AN INTERESTING THOUGHT.
A SIMPLE EXERCISE.
LOOKING UP THE COLOR BARS THAT
YOU PUT UP ON THE SCREEN.
I THINK ALL THOSE THINGS.
YOU HAVE DANCING NEEDLE MEN.
YOU HAVE COLOR BARS, AND WHAT
WAS THE LAST EXAMPLE?
3.5 EQUALS ZERO.
THEY ARE SO CRINGEWORTHY BECAUSE
YOU WANT TO LAUGH BUT THE PEOPLE
SAYING THEM ARE ACTUALLY
SERIOUS.
HER >> Pete: EXACTLY.
IT'S LIKE COWS FARTING ARE GOING
TO END LIKE THE PLANET, NOT THE
ISLAMISTS ARE THE MARXISTS.
ANY OTHER EXAMPLES.
THE LEFT IS SO DAMN SERIOUS BUT
IT LOOKS LIKE A JOKE.
THAT'S WHY IT'S SO CRINGE EAT
FOR EVERYONE.
IT'S LIKE AOC IS A SERIOUS
THINKER.
>> Greg: WHY DO COWS FART SO
MUCH?
BECAUSE THEY ARE LACTOSE
INTOLERANT.
THEY MAKE IT.
IT'S RIGHT THERE.
IF YOU CAN REACH IT.
SOMETHING I LEARNED IN GRADE
SCHOOL.
CANDACE, WE CELEBRATED THREE
CRINGEWORTHY TOPICS.
THE FLAG REDESIGN, COLD BEERS
MUSICAL THEATER, JOE BIDEN NOT
DOING MATH.
PICK ONE.
>> Candace: IT'S COLD AIR.
-- IT'S COLBERT.
HE MAKES ME VERY NERVOUS.
I NEVER FEEL COMFORTABLE WHEN
HE'S DOING THAT.
THERE'S SOMETHING, HE COULD WIND
UP AS A DATELINE EPISODE.
COLBERT, I SAY THAT, DON'T DO
ANYTHING ME, I'VE NEVER BAD --
NEVER HAVE ANYTHING BAD TO SAY.
SO CRINGEWORTHY.
YOU SHOULD NEVER HAVE TO TRY
THAT HARD TO BE FUNNY.
HE TRIES SO HARD AND HE MISSES
THE MARK EVERY TIME.
>> Greg: I DON'T TRY HARD.
THAT'S WHY I MISSED THE MARK BUT
THE THING IS, WHAT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT, WHAT'S WEIRD IS A
BACKGROUND IN MUSICAL THEATER.
THINK ABOUT EVERYBODY YOU KNOW
THAT WAS SOMEHOW INVOLVED IN
MUSICAL THEATER.
WHERE ARE THEY NOW, KAT?
THEY ARE PROBABLY LIVING IN YOUR
APARTMENT.
>> Kat: I HAD TO BE THE
NARRATOR BECAUSE I CAN'T SING.
>> Greg: I WOULD LOVE TO HEAR
YOU SAYING.
YOUR DREAM IS TO BE A DATELINE
EPISODE.
FORENSIC FILES.
>> Kat: I DON'T WANT TO BE
MURDERED.
I AIM A LITTLE HIGHER THAN THAT,
GREG.
THE FLAG THING.
I'M CONFUSED HONESTLY.
I READ THIS ARTICLE, ONE OF THE
FLAKES THAT HAD SOMETHING TO
REPRESENT RACISM.
I WAS CONFUSED BECAUSE FLANKS AS
I UNDERSTAND THEM ARE THINGS THE
WAY AROUND TO BE LIKE YAY THIS O
ISN'T IT MORE OFFENSIVE IF THE .
WE DON'T PUT BAD THINGS ON
FLANKS.
WE DON'T HAVE A FLAG THAT SAYS
MODERATE TO SEVERE PLAQUE
PSORIASIS.
>> Greg: WHAT IS IT?
IT'S LIKE PICASSO VOMITED.
>> Kat: HE PROBABLY DID
SOMETIMES.
>> Greg: TYRUS, WHAT ARE YOUR
THOUGHTS?
>> Tyrus: FIRST OF ALL BULLS
DON'T RIDE BULLS.
>> Greg: I HAVE NO IDEA WHAT
HE MEANS.
>> Tyrus: THERE WAS A TIME IN
MY LIFE AND BEING COLOR-BLIND, I
WAS SAD ABOUT IT BUT I'VE NEVER
BEEN SO HAPPY TO BE COLOR-BLIND
AFTER WHAT I SOB THERE.
GRAY AND GREEN.
IMAGINE IF I COULD SEE COLOR, I
WOULD BE THROWING UP.
YOU GUYS ARE ALL WRONG.
THEY ARE TELLING THE TRUTH.
IT WILL COST YOU NOTHING BECAUSE
YOU WILL HAVE NOTHING.
THEY ARE LITERALLY TRYING TO TAX
CHILD SUPPORT.
AS IF WE DON'T GET ENOUGH, NOW
YOU'RE GOING TO TAX US ON THAT?
YOU GIVE YOUR KIDS MONEY TO GO
TO THE STORE.
YOU LITERALLY WON'T BE ABLE TO
PAY ANYTHING BECAUSE YOU HAVE
NOTHING.
THEY ARE TELLING YOU THE TRUTH.
THEY ARE JUST NOT TELLING YOU
THE REAL TRUTH.
BUT THAT'S HOW IT WORKS IN
PROGRESS OF LAND WHERE
EVERYTHING IS FUZZY AND WARM AND
NOTHING COSTS ANYTHING BECAUSE
WE ARE ALL IN A NICE PLACE
TOGETHER.
YOU CAN'T PAY YOUR BILLS AND WE
ARE ALL LIVING IN MODULAR HOMES
TOGETHER SO WE'LL ALL CLAIM TO
BE RICH WHEN WE ARE NOT KILLING
EACH OTHER BECAUSE THERE'S NO
POLICE AROUND TO KEEP US FROM
TRYING TO KILL EACH OTHER.
BUT IT'S PHENOMENAL.
>> Greg: WE'VE GOT TO MOVE ON.
BY THE WAY, I READ THE ENTIRE
SPENDING BILL.
YEAH, NO.
I READ A TWEET ABOUT IT.
DEVOTING $3 BILLION TO TREAT
EQUITY.
TREE EQUITY.
THERE'S AN INEQUALITY OF TREES
IN THE COUNTRY SO WE HAVE TO
BRING UP THE QUALITY OF TREES,
$3 BILLION.
FOLIAG